The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome, everybody.
So this is the one group meeting
that we'll have with
all you folks.
We really appreciate your
willingness to come and help
us teach 6-172.
Saman will explain what the
course is all about, and then
I will give a presentation,
a little bit, of what your
expected responsibilities are,
and then Eric, who is one of
our TAs, will present what the
first project that they've
been working on is all about.
We think we have a pretty good
acronym, OK, MIT POSSE.
Masters in the Practice of
Software Systems Engineering,
OK, and it is very much like a
posse, in that we're trying to
sort of deputizing you folks to
help us deal with this mass
of students that we deal with.
There's no way, given the
resources that we have
available at MIT, that we
could possibly give the
attention to each of the
students examples of code, and
so our strategy is to go out
and deputize some people to
help us teach.
As we'll discuss your
responsibility is not to do
any grading, OK, or even any
understanding of the course
content, OK?
But rather to ask good questions
of the students so
that they understand what
it's like to do software
development, and you'll see that
most of the students are
very immature when it comes
to coding practices.
They have taken a minimum of
one systems course before
this, basically.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Probably two
classes where they write
very small programs--
PROFESSOR: Where they write a
very small programs, so they
have no sort of sense
of writing scale.
Moreover the class that we're
teaching because it's on the
topic of performance
engineering, they are inclined
to break all the rules in
order to get the best
performance.
And that's part of our game but
of course what we want is,
we want the countervailing--
you still have to make things
maintainable, you really
should do it this way, yeah
it's fine to violate some
abstractions here and there, but
then you should document
that you're violating those
abstractions and so forth.
And that's what we're counting
on you for, is to insert some
experience and common sense.
So, Saman, take it away.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, good,
so to add to what Charles
said, when I was an undergrad,
when I took something like a
science class, or a physics
class, or engineering class,
most of the problems had kind
of right answer and a wrong
answer and then it's very easy
to grade those things.
But when I took something like
an English class, all the
papers I wrote, somebody really
went through carefully
and graded it and gave me lot
of insightful comments so I
can kind of develop my
own style of writing.
And what happens in software is
the programming there's a
style that each individual has
to develop their style, but
they can't develop a very
haphazard style so there's a
certain set of good styles,
certain bad styles.
And the problem that is in a
large class we can grade for
correctness very easily, we can
also look at the programs
and have a very fast thing,
okay, saying, here are no
comments, or your comment
doesn't seem to be, it's too
verbose, or some very high level
feedback, but it's very
hard to help somebody
build their style.
And so what you guys are coming
into is to help us get
these young students create
their own style of
programming.
The nice thing about
this class--
and also sometimes last year the
masters found it a little
bit hard was, we are giving
them small amount of code.
They are doing performance
engineering on a maximum
couple of hundred
lines of code.
There's no very complicated
class structures or
something like that.
So we are not looking at the
style and software engineering
in the macro level, how to
structure large classes but
more at the micro level.
In each method do they
have right style?
Are they is it clean?
Are they commenting
them properly, or
can they do it better?
So at that level at least the
building blocks that they're--
as they go build a larger and
larger program they can
hopefully use.
So that's what we're looking at,
and it helps to instead of
dumping you ten thousand lines
of code, you only get a couple
of hundred lines of code, so you
can actually go through it
a lot more carefully,
and help them out.
So this is starting with a crazy
eye chart that is our
new curriculum that we
introduced in the department.
So what you have is some early
courses in here, these are
basically very general
math courses, early
courses that do--
they probably write about ten
lines of code type thing in
these courses, and then we feed
into these foundation
courses and then after that
we sit at, this says 197,
actually what should be 172.
We sit at that level, so we are
sitting at that level, and
then the prerequisite for people
who are coming is that
they're taking a computer
architecture course so they
know a little bit about
architecture.
They have taken this
introductory software course,
so they have written some Java
programs, and so they know a
little bit about software
engineering from that course,
and they have taken algorithms
course, so they understand
algorithms somewhat, so this
is the background of the
people are coming in.
At the low end there might be
some people who have only
written couple of thousand lines
of code in their lives,
and there are other people who
are, written half probably--
the Linux kernel.
So there are kind of very
diversified group of people.
But there's some people who it's
really new to them, and
they don't even understand why
you had to do good nice
programming, why do you have
to document these things.
I mean, for them it's a very
new concept, because they
haven't seen that.
So OK, if you're writing ten
lines, OK, why do you need
document that, I know
how to do this.
So part of that is this is,
for a lot of them it's eye
opening, and in last year also
we talked to students, they
actually gained a lot from
talking to you guys.
It's easy for us to tell them
do it, a lot of them say OK,
just to get the grade, I will
do it, but after that I'm
never going to do these things,
and they just go off
in very like, mad at us for
asking them to do it, but when
you guys say this is what
happens in industry, there's a
lot more impact on what
they're going to do.
And so I would go through very
fast, so we have done case
study on Matrix Multiply show
doing how you can basically do
things like algorithmic tricks,
architecture tricks,
and stuff like that
get really good
performance on Matrix Multiply.
So we started with doing very
object oriented, immutable
type matrices, Matrix
Multiply and then go
down to doing blast.
How much a performance gap
do you think that has?
AUDIENCE: It probably depends
on how big the
matrices are because--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah
it is 2k by a 2k
matrix so it is, yeah--
So somebody said 200x.
AUDIENCE: 10x
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah 10x,
so actually, in fact we've
been-- since I started with
the immutable matrix, very
object oriented stuff like
that, and then did all to
optimize I could,
I got 300,000x.
So this is kind of extreme case,
but it illustrates how
much, kind of, performance
sometimes is hidden in these
applications.
And then we talk bunch about,
these are done lectures, talk
about some very simple things
in performance engineering,
how to optimize loops, things
like how to get the compiler
to do certain things.
Some basic facts, we have bunch
of rules in there that
we went through fast.
And we are going to do introduce
them to performance
analysis for a lot
of these people.
First of all, they don't even
know their code is running
bad, because they don't know how
to look at it other than
getting one number then.
Even if they know that their
code is running bad, how do
you go about figuring
out what's going on?
They know a little bit about
GDB but they don't know
anything about performance
analysis, so we are
introducing them to
tools in here.
And we are talking about C to
Machine Code, lot of them are
Java programmers, we already
gave them a C primer, saying
if you're Java what does C
mean, kind of a thing.
And I actually talk about
computer architecture today
and talk about the entire
process they're going to use.
They're using this Nehalem
processor and all of the
interesting things that happen
inside the processor that they
had to be aware of.
And the same, maybe I will talk
about the memory system
optimization, and then Charles
is going to talk about
algorithms and data structures
for caches in there and some
about storage allocation.
We'll have a bunch of lectures
on parallelism that Charles is
going to use Cilk Language to
illustrate how to write
parallel programs, that's
what we are going
to use in this class.
And then more on parallelism,
some things like data
synchronization issues, dig deep
into other performance
issues in parallelism
in there.
And then since their final
project is on Ray Tracing,
we'll introduce them to a Ray
Tracing primer, and see how
Ray Tracing is done
and so they can go
into their final project.
Then I'm going to talk a little
bit about compile
optimization, what compilers can
do for you, and how to get
compilers to do those
things for you.
And a little bit about
distributed systems, so how
can you scale out
on this point?
It's about getting a small piece
of code to run fast, now
how do we get millions of users
go to this very large
scale system, and get
them to work, and
what issues are involved.
And then we are going to also
have about three or four case
studies sprinkled around.
We'll get someone from
University come and talk
specific problems, OK, look I
had this problem, and at the
beginning it was bad.
Here's how I went about figuring
out why and here are
the things I tried, these are
things worked, these didn't
work, and how we went go.
So kind of a very hands on
case studies about doing
performance because what these
people has to do is develop a
methodology.
Their own methodology of how
to go about solving these
problems, and then looking at
these case studies will give
them a feel how a very
experienced person will go
about looking at some
of those problems.
So these are the kind
of lectures we
are doing in a nutshell.
So the projects we are doing.
So students' mission, what
we do is we write some
inefficient piece of code, not
that long, and we give them
the specific, here so this is
functionally correct but it
runs darn slow.
And what you can say is, OK,
take advantage of right now,
the first project is basically
looking at algorithmic and
data structure inefficiencies.
So OK, trying to find better
ways of doing that and change
this program to run faster.
So that's their thing, so they
don't have deal with thousands
of lines of code.
Small program, it's correct, to
run them faster, and this
we'll also be asking them to
write tests, so you can
actually test their
implementation, and make sure
that implementation
are also correct.
And basically there's
no right answer.
This drives students crazy
because they are like, "When
am I done?" I'm like, "You're
never done until the
deadline," because you can keep
doing more and more and
you could keep increasing
performance in there, and of
course if you hit very marginal
returns and at some
point and you might decide,
OK, that's good enough.
And also more times
the journey is as
important as the outcome.
So at the end of the day you
can say I got it very fast,
but how did you get there?
What's the process
you followed?
Some of these programs are easy
to get there, but if you
haven't learned that process
you can't scale it out.
And so, a lot of times your part
is to talk to them and
say, "What did you do?" And say,
"Okay look why did you
skip that stage, why didn't you
profile it?" And get them
to get do that.
And some will say, "Yeah, I
just look at it, I realize
what it is." Like, no just do
something there might be
something hidden in there, so
get through the process,
understand the process,
that's the important.
So the way the project works is,
we give them a project, we
start them the project, and
there might be, some projects
have two parts in there, and
final and a project request
design document for them to
give us, saying what they
figure out what's bad and what
kind of optimizing they are
thinking of doing
in this project.
And then we have a thing
called a beta turn-in.
They said OK look we ran this,
we got the project and turned
the product in, an we call
it a beta, because
I'll tell you why.
And then what we do is, we run
everybody's project against
everybody, basically we run
every project, and we figure
out who got the fastest
implementation.
And we said OK, we announced
this and said this is the
fastest implementation, and then
we figure out how off are
you from the fastest, and we
have a proportion of the grade
that's basically computer
graded.
So we figure the fastest, you'll
get 100% for something
that on the other hand if you
are 10x slower you get 10%.
Except, the first time we tried,
the fastest was 1,000x
better than the slowest, so
somebody got like 0.1%, that
didn't work, so we are doing
square root of the former so
they'll be little
bit more, in the
somebody, got 1,000x there.
So sometimes it's because
somebody just missed one
critical insight and so and also
they might not have done
the test properly and stuff
like this, so we give them
opportunity.
And then after this beta turn-in
you get this code, and
the TAs get this code to run and
do a very fast check over
that and that, and then they
are going to have a week to
find a time with you, sit down
for hour or 90 minutes, and go
through this code.
And then they will get all the
feedback, the performance
feedback, and they can talk to
people and figure out what
they missed and they get another
chance to fix all
those things, get the
performance up to turn in, and
there'll be another performance
measurement, but
now if they match up to that
point, they can get a full
amount so of course, if people
exceed they don't get extra,
because we want to limit the
competition, but at least you
get a chance to kind of match
up the best code.
So, what you have is this design
review week, that they
get to talk to you, and get
feedback and, then after that,
they fix everything up
and then resubmit it.
PROFESSOR: You should mention
the beta tests.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yes, so what
also we do in this is
we're asking them also to create
a test suite, and we
are going to run everybody's
programs against everybody's
test suite, and also give them
points on coverage of their
suite, and also how well
their program does
against everybody else.
So if somebody finds lot of
bugs in other programs, or
some there's a test that founds
couple of bugs that
nobody else found we will give
a lot of points for that
person, because that means they
went and did a really
good job in creating
a test suite.
So we are actually using that
to basically emphasize on
testing and testability
issues in there.
And then final, when you're turn
in, then the TAs will, at
that point, will grade for
performance and also the
coding style.
So that time they will go to the
code and assign the grade.
And so if the students have
listened to you, and carried
out what you said, they should
get really good grades on that
part, and then they had
to also provide
a write up in that.
So this is kind of the flow
of the projects we have.
And the project one is a simple
algorithmic and data
structure trick.
So we did things like data
rotator, bit flip counter, and
this Pentominoes Puzzle
that he's going to
explain a little bit.
So we give these things, that
we have a pretty inefficient
representation, where most of
them has a much better bit
representation, and you can do
bit tricks to basically get
good performance.
So these are algorithmic and
data structure representations
that can have huge performance
gains.
So this is the first project
and this is what next week
you're going to get.
So project two is more about
memory system performance,
things like image rotator
and number sorting.
We have two parts, the first
part is we give them these
problems, and they're supposed
to run with different data set
sizes, look at performance
counter results and identify
what's going on with
these programs.
So there's one thing that
we'll give them bunch of
source compiled, and they have
to figure out which sort is
which by looking at performance
counters and
different ones.
So you had to identify, so
basically give them idea to
basically observe a program
behavior, and then we ask them
to go and fix some of
the performance
issues as a second part.
So this is a lot about basically
getting performance
information, understanding a lot
of hardware, what's going
on and then going and doing
some performance fixes.
So there'll be two parts,
to this project.
And the project three
is implementing
efficient storage allocator.
Most of these students find
after they've done the Java
and Python, they come thinking
there are these objects
running in memory, with a thing
called pointer that
points to, and to understand
what a pointer is
is sometimes hard.
And this is an interesting
example that they actually do
a lot of pointer manipulations,
and you have to
get a lot of those things right
and you have to have
good discipline to do that,
as well as getting some
performance, so this is
interesting project in there.
Here you don't get too much of
performance variance but
students have to think very
carefully about basically
aliasing data structures
and stuff like that.
So getting some of this dirty
little things you have to do,
and learning how do it right.
And then we go into parallel
programming.
So first part is introducing
the concept of parallelism
giving them some simple
programs to basically
parallelize, and then the second
part is we give them
insertion detection we're
inserting a bunch of lines
into a image and then they have
to figure out when these
lines move when they actually
intersect, and so it's not
embracing a parallel, you
have to actually do by
intersegmenting the data into
regions and basically figuring
out where communication is.
So there's a lot of issue
in there to get it done.
It's a fairly complex program
that they have to to deal with
and so they're going to have
to think through a lot of
parallelism issues,
synchronization issues,
communication issues, all
those things come
into play in here.
And then project 5 is just a
problem set because we want to
get to make sure that they
understood some basic material
we did, so you don't have
to deal with that.
We give them, actually, a write
up they don't have to do
any coding in there and they
turn that in as a normal
problem set.
And the project six also you
don't have time to critique
that because it is delivered the
last day of class, but if
you're interested in basically
giving them some feedback, or,
just come in to the finals
and see how they do.
So there what they do is, this
is a really fun project, we
give them a very unoptimized ray
tracer, and we okay here's
an image that it can generate.
If you generate image that
looks the same to
us, you'll be OK.
So you can change the algorithms
you are doing, come
up with other things you can
do, where you can still
maintain the visual equivalence
and then you can
do that, you can optimize, you
can parallelize, you can do
anything you want and
build a ray tracer.
So they go and then we explain
to them the basics of ray
tracing and they do lot of cool
things and a lot of these
kids actually really change,
think through algorithmic
issues, even look at a lot of
graphics and find different
ways, or better ways of doing
things, and come up with
really cool tricks and
then do really well.
So for that we will invite
you guys to come to the--
then we will have basically a
bake off, everyone will come
and figure out who has the
fastest ray tracer, and they
have the bragging rights, as
well as the grade of having
the fastest ray tracer, so--
PROFESSOR: I'm going
to go through this.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Okay, you
go through-- we have the
schedule here.
So the most programs are done in
C, and very little C++, not
very complex C++ classes,
or anything like that.
We want them to be very
close to the metal.
They have been trained in a lot
of abstract programming in
Java, Python and stuff like
that, now they're going to get
to the metal, and understand
things like pointers, malloc
and free, native data types
and stuff like that.
We're not dealing with things
like dealing in garbage
collection and bound checks, and
all the other things, so
they're really seeing what's
going close to the metal, and
sometimes we are even
encouraging to look at at a
little bit of assembly work,
that's not really required.
AUDIENCE: Have these students
had exposure to any kind of
assembly language programing?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: In 004, they
are using some assembly
programming for in the
architecture class, but I
think it's a very simple, I
think RISC machine inspection
they're doing.
And then we will have our course
website as you go about
you can look at what the course
is doing and also if
you change this F10 to a F09 you
will see last year's code.
So you can actually even see
into the future what we have
been doing.
So if you want to kind of
preface from the front.
AUDIENCE: I took a look at this
website and found that
most of it was unavailable
because of--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We should
have Word readable we need to
make it if it's not
Word readable--
AUDIENCE: It says it's
Word readable.
To us.
GUEST SPEAKER: Some of it is a
lot of it was not I've said
you need to, I mean it's
all available for-
AUDIENCE: Certificate?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We will check
that, because all this
things that we have set up
in the background to get
everything Word-- we want to
make everything Word readable,
so we'll make sure
that happens.
So, OK, so that's all I have
about the class and one thing
interesting more so this
projects, the best to worst
can sometimes be 1,000x
difference.
So what that means, even for the
people who are struggling,
they can get something
out of the class.
But unlike other classes where
you just read the limit and
then you're bored, you can
really keep pushing the limit,
especially things like the final
product, the people who
did well really pushed the
limits, they could have done
that for a graphics
class type thing.
I mean they pushed algorithms
changes, did amazing
parallelization techniques, data
partitioning, everything.
And where some people just kind
of stayed within that and
did some small parallelization
got some like low hanging
fruit in there.
I mean what we're trying to do
is, computer science these
days, we get some students, as
I said, their first time
they're coding anything more
than ten lines and other
people who are already a
submitter for open source
projects, who have written
millions of lines of code, we
have these two.
And these codes, I think we
are trying to cater to at
every level, and keep everybody
basically very
motivated, and excited
to be in there.
And I think the last year it
was a pretty good success.
And they really enjoy meeting
masters last year, and after
we go to discussion we can talk
about that a little bit.
PROFESSOR: So we have two
websites, as Saman mentioned
before, so here they are, and
then here's the schedule.
So we'll run through this, in
more detail for what is
expected of you, in a moment,
but basically there's four
projects that's sort of are
organized along here.
Oops, that typo didn't
get fixed.
That's should be November 19
obviously there, instead of
October 19 if you
want to correct
that on your calendars.
OK, so in general it begins with
an information session
which you're allowed to attend
in person but most people just
dial in, it's more convenient.
Then we will provide you with
the beta code submitted by
your four students and then
you'll have two meetings that
typically are 60 to 90 minutes
with each of your two pairs.
OK, so let's go through
how this is working.
So the first thing is just to
make sure you folks recognize
that you're making
a commitment.
It's very difficult for us, and
it's even more difficult
for the students, to cope with
something that happens
mid-term, OK?
Where suddenly their master
disappeared, or whatever, so
we're very big on
anti-flakiness, if you will.
And so if you believe that
there's going to be a problem
please let us know as much
in advance as you can.
Sometimes things are
unavoidable, they come up, we
don't fault you for that
or anything, OK?
Just let us know, we'll try to
deal with the situation.
But for the most part we're
really asking you to make a
strong commitment to the
class, and so if your
situation is such that you're
unsure it's best to talk with
us or politely decline to
participate, rather than
putting on the rosy glasses,
say, "Oh yeah I think I can do
this, even though I know that
I've got a major deadline that
conflicts with one of these
projects," or whatever.
It's just really difficult
on the
students when things change.
They are sort of going I don't
know if you remember what it's
like being in school as an
undergraduate, but pretty much
the students go sort of hand
to mouth, in terms of like,
they look and they say, OK I got
this deadline this week I
better work on that one.
They don't really look ahead and
so forth, and so it's up
to us, to some extent, to
recognize that they're in that
mode and that we need
to do things to make
that easy for them.
When they get sick or something
mid-term it can
really throw a student way off
for the term, and so certainly
when something happens to the
staff, that sort of, at that
caliber, can really knock them
off their trajectory.
The design and code reviews
should normally be held at
MIT, and the students will
have some locations.
If you are within walking
distance to campus however,
you may suggest an alternative
place to meet, such as at your
own workplace, if that's more
convenient for you, OK?
But if a student balks at
doing that you shouldn't
pressure them to accept.
The content of the off campus
meetings should be
professional, it's strictly
the review process, no lab
tours, no free lunches, or
dinners, or what have you, OK?
And we'll talk a little bit
more about that later.
But the main thing about them is
that they can be scheduled
in the evening or you know
whatever time you and your two
students find convenient
to get together, OK?
There's no limits as to
when you know what
time those can be.
They can be on the weekend they
can be, whatever you can
work out, very flexible.
So here's the basic guidelines,
each master is
responsible for reviewing
the code
produced by four students.
The students typically will work
in teams of two or three
for the projects, OK?
So what you will have is your
four students will be
organized into two review groups
of two students each,
but none of the students will
be on the same project.
The reason for that is that we
want to make sure that every
student who goes to represent
their project can represent
the whole project.
So they're responsible for
They don't have a buddy there
on the same team, who can
cover for them when you're
asking them questions about
their project.
You ask them questions they've
got to be able to answer about
the whole thing, even
if they didn't code
every piece of that.
We're encouraging them generally
to do things like
pair programming, so they
really should understand
what's going on throughout.
The reason for having two
groups, rather than meeting
them individually, it turns out
there's actually some good
knowledge of one of them sort of
being able to see what the
other teams are doing.
So generally they're not
allowed to share their
solutions, et cetera, with
other teams, but in this
meeting that's OK.
The ideas and so forth can come
but they shouldn't be
making copies for each
other of the code
of the other group.
But they can say, oh is that
what the other team did, And
so forth, and there can be
some learning for them to
submit the final project.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Also last
year, lot of masters very
successfully used the other team
members to kind critique
each other.
So showing something do you
understand this, and then they
can look at it and say, "Yeah,
I can see what's going on,
that's very useful," also when
we go to masters we can talk
about of that type of thing.
PROFESSOR: Also things
like documentation.
You can look at the code there
and ask the other one, "Do you
understand what that
documentation
says?" And so forth.
It turns out it's actually
easier than that, because
usually if the documentation
is inadequate, the student
himself has trouble remembering
what they did, right?
I mean you know how this
works with code, so.
So consequently you're
responsible for generally for
two review meetings for each
of the four projects.
Now as it turns out we'll assign
things, we're going to
have things like students
dropping the class, and so
there will be some minor
reshuffling as we go on.
Some of you may end up with only
one team of two students.
Some of you may find that you're
reconstituting it.
In some cases if we end up--
we may ask somebody, "Can you
cover an extra team this time
because somebody is going
to be out of town?" Or
something like that.
So there may be some variations
on this, but this
is basically how things go.
Now, one thing you should
understand is that you are not
going to grade the students.
So, one of the things I learned
long ago was that when
you grade somebody they behave
differently than if you don't.
So you're not grading them that
has a plus and a minus.
The plus is that then this is
really pure feedback for them.
This is to help them, they know
that you're supposed to
have read it.
The downside is some students
will say, "Eh, then I don't
need to listen, because nobody's
holding a stick over
my head." But the reason
we do that is twofold.
One is because we think that the
quality of interaction is
better, and the second reason
is because you're not
empowered by MIT
to give grades.
So you won't be grading them.
You're also not responsible
for the technical
content of the class.
We're going to be teaching
stuff, hopefully which is
sufficiently new, some of it,
that some of you may not know
all of what we're teaching with
respect to parallelism,
and so forth.
Some of you may that's great,
but that's not the role.
We will take responsibility
for teaching the
content of the class.
What we're really after here
is for you to listen as an
experienced program developer,
and provide feedback to the
students about software
engineering.
In other words explained to
them what's going on. "Why
didn't you write that in
your documentation?
How come all your variables
have only one letter?
Why is this stuff wrapping
around three
lines before you--
why no white space?"
This kind of stuff.
So, remember they're very smart
students, but they're
also very immature
many of them.
Some of them you'll discover
are like way mature, but
there's going to be some of them
that are just absolutely
this is new to them, and
what they need is some
encouragement and some
suggestions as to what they
can do to improve the quality
of their code.
And since we're not in a
position to review it, why
we're deputizing you as members
of the MIT POSSE, is
to deputize you to help them
produce better quality code,
which is not something that's
easy for us either to give
feedback on, or to grade.
So hopefully when we are grading
them in the end on
their final submission and the
quality of things, it reflects
that they've learned something
from you folks about
producing good code.
Also you want to be careful,
this is one of the bugs I have
when I interact with the
students is, I tend to do most
of the talking if I don't
check myself.
And one of the really good
things is to have a guideline
that they I don't know how many
of you have teenage kids,
and if you lecture them how
quickly they learn right?
No, they don't.
So the goal here is to
help them learn.
And so lecturing usually
doesn't work.
What works generally is getting
them to do the talking.
And then it's great
to pepper your
interactions with anecdotes.
I work with one person who did
this, or early in my career I
did this and here's how
it blew up in my face,
that kind of thing.
Excellent to have anecdotes that
you can give with real
world experience.
Why you might think it's like
this, but in fact, if you do
it that way you're headed
down a very bad path.
Let me tell you story
about that.
That's fine, OK.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Or if you
find a very stubborn person
saying, "If you do that
I won't hire you."
PROFESSOR: That counts too.
You would never get a job here
if you coded like that.
And in fact that's actually
what Saman says, that's
actually one of the big benefits
of having folks from
industry providing that
feedback, because we can say
that, if you do it like that you
wouldn't be hired by XYZ
corporation.
You can say that, but if you
say, I wouldn't hire you, if
you did that, that has
a, it's like, oh!
It has a big impact, whereas
when we do it it's
like eh, you know.
It's like what do they know?
So the guideline is make them
do a lot of the talking, so
that they're trying to explain
and you teach them a little
bit what a design and
code review is.
Now, in fact what your
review is, is both
design and code review.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: To add to
that, what we have told them
is to prepare for what a filing
statement type thing,
to walk through and explain
what they did to you guys.
So they will come with some
preparations stuff that they
can do that, let them, both of
them kind of do that, and then
start them off the
instructive part.
PROFESSOR: And maybe
they'll do that.
But that's the goal is, you
should say, "Look, when you
come you should prepare
something that brings me up to
speed," and teach them a
little bit about what's
expected of them when
you have a design or
code review in industry.
So for each of the projects, as
we mentioned, there will be
a short information session,
typically by dialing
conferencing, except
for this one, which
we'll do in a minute.
After the students have
submitted their beta releases
we will get the code to you.
Last year we had the students
responsible for getting the
code to the MIT POSSE, and that
was basically a nightmare
for everybody involved.
So this time we will make sure
that we get you their code,
and I hope that way the
unreliability--
I don't know if you remember
but like, these are mostly
like juniors and seniors, and
when you're juniors and
seniors you're not 100% reliable
in everything you do
and your word is your bond is
not necessarily, oh I forgot
that my word is my bond,
kind of thing, right?
So by us getting it to you,
we'll remove one layer
hopefully of flakiness.
Next what you'll do is, you'll
coordinate to meet with a
mutually agreeable time, and
then after the review you're
going to provide us with a
little bit of feed back, it
doesn't have to be long, just a
short email, not as a grade
or evaluation, but to help us
understand where the student's
are doing well, and what
they're missing.
So what we may need to stress
in class and so forth.
And then, of course, after
the review, they have the
opportunity to make changes to
their code before they submit
their final revision.
Now, that's a little bit
different from industry where
you would go through typically
some kind of feature freeze,
and code freeze, and so forth.
Our beta is beta sort of in
name, but not necessarily in
all aspects, in that they can
actually completely rewrite
their code between the beta
and the final version.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So in your
feedback you can also tell a
little bit about in your
interactions what worked and
what didn't.
This is the first time, as far
as we know anybody's doing
this kind of a thing anywhere.
We are also developing
a process so
good practice is very--
PROFESSOR: And since your email
will go to MIT POSSE and
everybody will read it, what
hopefully you can do is, some
of the practices that you find
useful, I tried this at work,
I tried this, it didn't work.
That starts to get spread out
among you and is becomes very
helpful for each other to say,
"Oh, well that was an
interesting idea let me try
that." And so we hopefully
we'll be able then to start
compiling some best practices.
AUDIENCE: Will we be identifying
students by name
in those broadcasting minutes?
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes, in fact
here's the thing is, what
you're going to do is give,
well it one, names the
students who attended, and that
helps us keep track of
who's actually going to
these and who isn't.
The strengths and weaknesses in
the student presentations.
Some suggestions for improving
the assignment.
That's suggestions for us to
improve the assignment for
them, and any other comments.
So we got some really good
feedback last year that, "Hey
the code you're handing out as
the initial code that was
really sloppily documented."
Last year we were much more
behind the eight-ball in terms
of trying to do this.
This time we've had more time,
and in particular we also have
some really outstanding TAs
who've worked very hard on the
software engineering
of the project.
So I think that we'll be better
in that regard, this
year, than we were last year.
AUDIENCE: I just
had a question
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
they're going to give to you
and you're going to
pass the code out.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you mean just the
code or are you thinking
structured more as a design
review, they really will be
talking about, a
review package.
It would be the code plus I
don't know whether you're
doing documentation generation
or any sort of an intro or
front matter?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
question is whether in
addition to the code there
should there's going to be any
other documentation, or
package, or whatever.
In fact, most of the final
documentation is going to be
for the final project and not
for the beta, and so they
should have things well
documented within the code,
for example about what their
strategies are, and how they
work, and so forth, but there
won't generally be a write up.
They should be providing you at
your meeting with a brief
outline of what's going on, and
you can ask them after the
first meeting for any other
thing that you think would be
helpful to them and to you in
making the design meeting more
productive.
One of the things always in
these things is how much do
you require out of the students
and at which time.
They have in this project, we're
on a relentless series
of deadlines for them.
And so we've tried to do as
much as we can while being
still relatively minimalistic
in asking for too
much stuff too early.
And so it would be great if they
had a complete package of
here's what's going on, the
fact is that they were up
really late the night before
trying to get this stuff done,
they've also had to submit beta
tests and so we decided
that the final write up of how
their project worked, et
cetera, we would save for the
final, and it won't be
something, in English written
like that will only be in the
code, it won't be as
a separate package.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions
about that?
OK, so one final word,
relationships with students.
So one of the things that MIT
has, and many other places
have, I'm sure that you're
aware, that if you're in a
power position with somebody,
and this in particular applies
at MIT with students, you must
ensure that all your
relationships are strictly
educational.
And what that means is like
a, no romance, OK, duh.
But it also means in this
context, no recruiting, hints
at job opportunities, offers
of summer internships, lab
tours, et cetera, free dinners,
and so forth.
Your job has to be completely
educational.
However when the term is over
you're welcome to continue
your friendship in a non-power
relationship.
There's no longer a power
relationship you're welcome to
start a romance with one of the
students if you will, but
in particular, allowed to seduce
them to come to your
company as a summer intern,
or a job or what have you.
So you're welcome to do that but
not during the term, those
sorts of things are absolutely
off bounds.
Now the students themselves may
say, "Hey do you guys have
summer internships, and so
forth?" And it's up to you
folks to draw the line and say
something like, "Yes, we do,
but if you're interested in
that, we can talk about that
after the term is over,"
for example.
So, put them off in some way,
and return the conversation to
the educational mission
for the term.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what if the
students do a good job?
PROFESSOR: Yes, but then you
run the risk of it being
interpreted as a quid pro quo
for employment, which is
exactly the thing that we're
trying to steer away from.
They're smart MIT students, I
think they'll figure out that
if they're interested in a
summer internship they should
be impressing their mentor.
Not all of them figure
this out, by the way.
AUDIENCE: So just to clarify.
Just to clarify, it's okay to
say, "If you write your code
this way, I won't hire you."
But it's not OK to say, "I
wouldn't hire you." I just
want to clarify.
PROFESSOR: You'd say I wouldn't
hire you, OK, my
company would not hire
somebody who wrote
their code like this.
You could say that.
AUDIENCE: But it's not okay to
say my company looks for
people who would write
code this way?
PROFESSOR: No, I think
that would be OK too.
No, the issue is whether you
personalize it, right?
If you're interested in a summer
job, I can get you a
summer job, all you have to do
is, dadadadadadadaaa, and now
they feel like there's another
master to serve.
So what we want to avoid is
having them feel like there's
another obligation on top
of the obligation
they have to the class.
They should not feel that in
some ways they're obliged to
do something for you in order,
for example, to get a job.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Or
get a good grade.
PROFESSOR: Or get a
good grade, or--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: If I say no
to the summer job they're
going to badmouth me and I will
fail this class or get a
bad grade, and then.
So, that put them in a binding
situation that they won't work
for the class, but they'll
feel obliged
to something else.
PROFESSOR: You're in a power
situation, and you're in a
situation where you must not let
them have any sense that
there's any power relationship
there, if you
will, in other words--
AUDIENCE: We shouldn't try to
extort meals from them.
PROFESSOR: For example.
Exactly, exactly.
Also if you feel anything
awkward is developing, let
Saman, or me, this is something
for which the staff
only email is better than
probably the MIT POSSE one.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Or
even to us directly.
PROFESSOR: Or even to us
directly, although I actually
think it better to go
via the staff only.
It really is much better to go
get via staff only, because
the TAs need to know what's
going on with all the students
in class as well.
Question back here.
AUDIENCE: Two logistical
questions but I don't want to
interrupt you before
you finish.
PROFESSOR: No, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Okay, it's not clear
to me do we meet with the same
four students throughout
the term?
PROFESSOR: If possible
we will do that.
Because otherwise what happens
is, they hear it from one and
then they go to another.
So this way there's some amount
of continuity, but that
won't happen perfectly because
students will drop and we'll
have to reconstitute
groups and things.
GUEST SPEAKER: The winners get
David and the losers get me.
That's OK.
I just wanted to be clear.
Also you e-mail the code
to us before we do
the sit down session?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
GUEST SPEAKER: Are we expected
to review it by ourselves
beforehand?
PROFESSOR: I think it helps
to take a look at it, yes.
GUEST SPEAKER: As opposed
to walk in cold
and doing just that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yes, that's
right, I mean I think you do a
better job if you have looked at
the code beforehand to see,
oh my goodness this is,
and take a few notes.
But for this we're relying on
you to use your best judgment
for what's the best
way of giving
feedback to the students.
But I think generally the reason
we email it to you in
advance is specifically so you
have a chance to look it over.
Once again we're not so
concerned about whether the
content of what they're learning
in it as much as--
you look at it, it will take you
two seconds as soon as you
see one piece of undergraduate
code, it'll take you two
seconds to say, I don't care
what this thing does this
student needs to learn X.
I mean you will see.
Is that the feedback, from
people who took this--
AUDIENCE: You'll know
it when you see it.
PROFESSOR: Any other comments
from people
from last year what--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, a
couple comments.
One very minor sort of
procedural things.
Personally, I found it a lot
more useful to me to show up
in person for the information
sessions than do it by
conference call, if for no other
reason then a lot of
people who called in had issues
with voice quality.
You know, just getting
a good quality voice
signal over the phone.
Also I found it very helpful
to have each student review
the other one's code.
So I would just do that to start
with, just hand it to
each other and here,
what do you think?
That also gives them some
experience of actually doing a
review, as well as being
the person who's
work is being reviewed.
PROFESSOR: That's a great
technique just because one of
the things that you want them
to do is empathize with the
person who's going to read the
code, and so, by putting them
in the situation where they have
to read somebody else's
code they very quickly learn
oh, this is, my goodness
that's exactly what I did to
the other one, so that is a
great technique.
AUDIENCE: The reference
implementations are we going
to get those--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Soon?
Early?
PROFESSOR: Yes, those generally
we will be able to
give you the reference
implementations at the
information session.
Or actually, we should probably
get it to them before
the information session.
AUDIENCE: I would suggest
before the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's get those
make sure we get those
to you before the information
session.
We'll get you a reference
implementation at least a few
days in advance.
AUDIENCE: OK, also something
that was a recurring issue
last year regarding the
reference supplementations
which was the...
there was some issues with
some of the reference
implementation--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: --software
engineering.
AUDIENCE: In particular things
like functions that should
have been local to a file they
were not declared static or,
that kind of thing, or macros
that should have been used or
that were used and shouldn't
have been.
PROFESSOR: Last year we were
running with a much larger
class than we expected, with no
infrastructure to speak of,
and we had two TAs who were flat
out, and so we definitely
cut corners.
This year the department has
been good to us, we have four
TAs, and so I think that the
quality is going to be higher.
That doesn't mean that the TAs
are seasoned 20 years of
software development experience
or more, either.
So they have some things to
learn too, but already based
on the first project we're
ahead of the game.
AUDIENCE: OK, also if from time
to time one of us wants
to attend the class?
PROFESSOR: Feel free to
attend the class.
AUDIENCE: OK, where's
the schedule?
PROFESSOR: It is Tuesdays and
Thursdays in 26-100 at--
AUDIENCE: Is it on
the website?
PROFESSOR: It's on the website
at 2:30 to 4:00.
So Tuesdays and Thursdays 2:30
to 4:00, you're welcome to
come and learn all about
performance engineering.
Reed, did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: No, I guess I was
just going to say that in
regard to the feedback, we
TAs here have got that.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: During class
last week most of the
TAs were students last year,
so they aren't learning
anything new.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry,
where is the class?
PROFESSOR: It's in 26-100
AUDIENCE: So it's not here?
PROFESSOR: No.
So this is the situation, we
outgrew our classroom which
seated 60, and we had 85 or 90
students, so they put us into
the next smaller classroom
that we would fit into.
That was 26-100 which
fits 500.
Then we found that in 26-100
you needed a microphone for
the students to hear you, even
though we had them all crowded
into one quarter of the
auditorium, you still then--
just the structure of it-- you
needed a microphone, so they
said, "That will be $85 a
lecture." And you say, "What
do you mean $85 a lecture?"
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Someone has
to walk in just to turn on--
PROFESSOR: To turn
on thing thing.
So, anyway we sorted all this
out OK, but it was sort of
funny that you're charging us
for being in a room that we
have no choice as to be in?
Anyway it was very funny.
AUDIENCE: Are your lectures
video taped are they
available--
PROFESSOR: They are
videotaped.
We are not planning to put them
up quick because what
that does is discourages
students from attending the
lectures, as you can imagine.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Mainly for
OCW OpenCourseWare So they
basically they could go to
OpenCourseWare they will
process it and they have to go
through a lot of legal stuff
and make sure the
named are right.
PROFESSOR: Are right
and so forth, yeah.
There is a bunch
of stuff there.
Good, so it says final words
here but they aren't really
final, because we still
have Eric to talk
about the first project.
But the feedback from the
students last year was that
the MIT POSSE was one thing that
made this one of their
favorite classes.
It was getting that kind of
seasoned feedback in a very
small group setting when you
look at the student faculty
ratio, that's one thing you're
always battling.
especially at MIT, where we are
in a very popular major,
and so the ability to recruit
all you folks to help that
ratio in favor of the students
is really very much
appreciated by students and
by us, so enjoy the term.
This is really rewarding the
people who have done it before
we had just tremendously
positive feedback from them
about just how rewarding it was
to work with these young
programmers.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: They are very
smart people, you can see
the changes, you will see
the you impact on them.
You will see you're molding
these people into better
programmers, so that's
the fun part.
PROFESSOR: So Eric is now going
to talk a little bit
about project one, and this is
similar to what we will do,
although most of you will
probably be on the phone
unless you heed Barry's advice,
for the future one.
So I'll get out of your way.
ERIC: So the project one this
is, I think, the one project
that was substantially different
from last year.
So, the code for this
project we, the TAs,
coded up this semester.
Did we give out the hand outs,
Saman, or Charles?
Yeah so these are the--
PROFESSOR: So this is the actual
assignment and we'll
share this with you,
plus the reference
implementation, I think.
ERIC: Well we'll send out the
reference implementation
tonight then.
In fact, now people have already
done their betas for
project one.
Project one has two parts, it's
a part called Every Bit
Counts and a part called
Tiling a Torus with
Pentominoes.
So the first part it's an
abstract data types of
modeling and bit array, packed
bit array and they are a given
a couple of tasks to do on
long strings of bits.
So you might have eight million
bits and there are two
functions to rotate the
substring of the bits by some
amount to the left or right, and
the other operation is to
count how many flipped
bits there
are in a given substring.
So the specific interface for
this, this an excerpt without
the comments from the header
file of this C module.
There is a couple of accessors
which accesses bits
individually those are not,
well those accessors are
currently used to implement,
in the reference
implementation, the rotate and
count flips operations.
So what they will need to do
is to go into the C module,
the implementation, and change
these functions, to basically
be 10,000 times faster, or
whatever, I can't remember
what they actually got.
In particular the rotate
operation is incredibly slow,
there's one constraint for them
and we're saying that,
well imagine that this is on the
cell phone or something,
where you have a really big
bit array, but you don't
really have very much more
memory to consume beyond that
big bit array.
So we're asking them to only
do this using a constant
amount of memory.
So that's the first problem
with these two parts, the
rotate and the count flips.
Any problem, questions about
that particular part?
Does it seem clear what?
AUDIENCE: What does the
count flips do?
ERIC: Oh yeah, so I should've
swap those two slides.
So, if you have a bit string,
suppose nine bits or
something, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, that would have to be 8.
If this is the substring you
want to count, then you count
transitions from zero to
one, or one to zero.
And there's some new tricks you
can do by for instance,
considering six--
AUDIENCE: Count the number of
runs, of consecutive value.
ERIC: Yeah, the number
of runs.
AUDIENCE: Plus plus one--
or minus one, yeah.
ERIC: That's right.
And you don't count the
beginning or the end as a
transition, so in this
particular substring there is
one there, one there,
and one there.
And it's not a substrings, it's
always substrings, it's
not the entire string, and you
can see that for instance, you
give us an argument, the bit
array and you say where the
starting offset and the number
of bits that the substring
that the substring is
and that's where the
operation is done.
So our testing routines will
do lots of rotations in
different parts of
that substring.
AUDIENCE: For the memory
constraint, do you have a
fixed size that they're
allowed to use or?
ERIC: We decided against
the fixed size.
We just say don't use malloc,
and you can allocate constant
amounts of memory, and the thing
is if they choose to
have a 16 megabyte or four
gigabyte lookup table then
their performance will
suffer anyway.
So yep?
AUDIENCE: What is the computer
architecture?
ERIC: What's that?
AUDIENCE: What is the computer
architecture?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We
are running on--
we got this donation from both
Intel and Dell, we have 16
machine-segments, each with two
six core processors and 48
gigs of memory.
So they're doing it on 12
cores so it becomes
interesting, and you got a
parallel 740 gigs, so we have
a lot of memory in these kinds
of things and we'll be asking
them to run through that.
So these were the latest
what's the word?
PROFESSOR: Core i7.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Core i7s.
PROFESSOR: Nehalem.
ERIC: For this first project,
we're asking them specifically
not to parallelize.
AUDIENCE: It's all on
Windows or Linux?
ERIC: Linux.
AUDIENCE: Linux?
ERIC: Yeah.
So the idea here is to exploit
bit operation and in
particular in rotates.
The reference implementation
does the really stupid thing
of you want sort of 4,000 bits
to the right rotates, well
I'll do it one at a time,
that's the reference
implementation.
But they're only allowed to us
a constant amount of memory,
so there is certain amount of
tricks you have to do to do it
in a more efficient way.
AUDIENCE: Do you stress in the
course about portable data
code from one operating
system to another, one
machine to the other.
PROFESSOR: This is where we
want you to stress the
importance of it, because that's
not something that
we're in a position to do or
enforce, or what have you, OK?
We let them assume for this
problem, for example, that the
machine they're working
on is Little Endian.
We talked about the issue, but
we did not insist that they
wrote code that would be that
would port to a Big Endian
machine, because they're running
on the Intel machines.
But this is exactly the kind
of thing where code quality
would say, portability,
maintainability, readability,
all these kinds of things, this
is exactly the kind of
thing we want you to say.
You say "Hey, you did it like
this, in fact did you know
that without sacrificing
anything in performance, you
could have made it portable from
one operating system to
another?" And then you could
talk about those issues, and
that's absolutely super,
to do that.
But we are not spending a lot
of class time doing that,
we're really focusing on the
performance engineering part
of the course.
ERIC: The reference
implementation should be
portable, so this should be
portable, although we did make
sure here, for instance, in the
reference representation
of bit array here, that the
order of the bits within each
bite happened to coincide
with the low end
ideas of these machines.
So that if you happen to cast it
to a 64-bit integer on each
of the bytes in the array then
you would get something that
was easy to work with on a
low end in architecture.
But the reference implementation
is portable
itself, or should be, so tell
us any kind of problems with
the reference implementation
like that.
The next problem is based
on the puzzle,
it's a puzzle solver.
It's this puzzle that I'd
never heard of before.
Apparently, if you generalize
dominoes you get Pentominoes
and the five end cases.
So there are this many
configurations of dominoes
with five squares on
them, I guess.
And the pentominoes puzzle is
you're given an eight by eight
board with four squares crossed
out, and now you're
supposed to arrange these so
that the entire board is
filled up, and only--
what's that?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You can
do flips of these--
ERIC: Oh, right.
You can do flips, you rotate
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: And
they will dissipate
and all those things.
ERIC: Right so the task is
find all the solutions,
although I believe in our
reference implementation that
was too fast, so we decided to
generalize the puzzle to the
toroidal case, where the board
wraps around the edges, just
to make it take a little
longer, to do.
PROFESSOR: Like space
boards right?
You go off the right edge you
come in the left edge.
AUDIENCE: Top and bottom also?
PROFESSOR: Top and bottom
also, yeah.
ERIC: So these two are
both examples of
solutions to this puzzle.
AUDIENCE: I've got
a question here.
ERIC: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Are you allowed
to put the empty space
where ever you want?
ERIC: Well, that's the
input to the solver.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Given
these empty spaces--
AUDIENCE: OK, and then
it fills in the rest.
ERIC: That's right.
Of course you can put
empty spaces so
that it can't solved.
And then they have to correctly
determine that
there's no answer.
PROFESSOR: That there's
no answer.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ERIC: And, also I believe the
reference solution takes days,
for certain.
To find all the solutions of
certain configurations of the
initial four dots.
So there's an option to the
program we give them, to just
find the first 2,000
or something.
PROFESSOR: So once again you can
see this is conducive to
bit tricks, where you represent
the board as a
64-bit word and then do masking
operations, and so
forth, to determine whether
a piece fits
and do clever shifting.
It's easy to shift a piece down
one row, where you're
trying it out, because that's
just a shift by eight, but how
do you shift it horizontally, to
come around on the other--
So they have to do some
shifting, some masking--
So anyway, the first project
is all about thinking about
bit representations of
things, and so forth.
ERIC: In fact, we give them a
solver that we don't really--
well, a searcher, routine to
search the space of possible
solutions, that we don't really
expect them to change,
but they can change it
if they want to do.
So, the interface here is
basically a board data
structure that they're free
to change the internal
representations of.
Or did we somehow prohibit
that due to testing?
No?
No, no, no, that's the
whole point, right.
So again, you have this basic
accessor for use by the
testing routines.
But then what you really need
to, well, you need to change
basically the entire
implementation of all of this,
if you're changing the
representation of the board,
for instance.
But this is the function that
should be running faster after
you're done, so I guess that
comment is misleading.
This is the function that is
supposed to run a lot faster
when you're done.
There is actual comments
in the header file.
So right, you give
it a function
pointer to a call back.
PROFESSOR: Now, one sort of
standard thing we decided
we're doing is, we're not trying
to write both 32 and
64-bit code in the classroom,
we're just going to do 64-bit.
So just one more level.
In practice you would want to
have stuff that runs both on
32 and 64, but for the most part
it's fine if they just
have it running on 64-bit.
ERIC: Right, so these by the
way are the initial four
points that are the input
to the puzzle.
I believe that's the
problem set one.
Questions about, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can students submit
more than one answer?
PROFESSOR: No.
Nope, they got to decide
what they're doing.
AUDIENCE: I guess I have a
question about the answer.
ERIC: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is an answer that is
probabilistically correct, I
mean like, it will sometimes
when you test it, you have it
pass all the test cases, but
mine isn't guaranteed to
necessarily always solve all
test cases is that OK?
ERIC: If they can conceal that
to us, then I think they--
PROFESSOR: They deserve
credit.
ERIC: Keep in mind that the
other half of the problem set
is to write test cases that
will catch as many obscure
bugs in the other students'
code as possible.
So they run the risk of
competing against--
PROFESSOR: They lose extra
points if they don't pass
their own tests.
AUDIENCE: They each need
to write some tests
that will be as--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so then they--
AUDIENCE: They exercise
somebody else's.
PROFESSOR: --to somebody
else's, yeah.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We are
running all the tests against
everybody else.
PROFESSOR: And then for the
final version we give them the
full regression suite of the
whole class, so they have very
good confidence, and we good
confidence that they're
handing in something
that is correct.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, so you
want to open up for--
PROFESSOR: For questions
or comments.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Especially,
I won't even mind the people
who did it last time, last time
to provide some of your
feedback on how we can...
[BUZZING NOISE]
PROFESSOR: Don't want
to do that?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah,
PROFESSOR: I was trying
to turn on the lights.
Do we have more lights
we can turn on?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Also, if you
could turn these on, too?
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah, so comments?
AUDIENCE: I want to say that's
why I was a master last year,
and I had a great time, but
I figured I'd stay--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, could
you stand up so
people can hear you?
Thanks.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
Give him a mic.
Give him a mic because I
think it'll be good--
PROFESSOR: It'll be good
to have these-- yeah.
All right?
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
So the first thing I found
really helpful was to take the
reference solution and actually
diff what the student
provide because they often just
provided a solution, and
if you don't know what they
started from, it was hard to
tell what they'd
actually done.
So diffing the two, that was
a good place to start.
And then I found incredibly
helpful just to spend 15 or 20
minutes prior to actually
meeting with them, looking at
the code and writing like two
or three or four things to
talk to them about.
And it might sound like it's
going to be highfalutin and
stuff, but it was like they're
using their returning function
pointers to local variables,
stuff like that.
It was really like what the hell
the makefiles were doing,
for example, is something
that I think they really
appreciated me telling
them that didn't get
talked about in class.
Especially once I got a good
rapport with them, they just
ask questions, and I spent the
whole time answering more
practical stuff about
the problem.
We had a good discussion, so
that's what I would suggest.
PROFESSOR: Thank you, that's
great feedback.
Yeah, as I say, don't
underestimate--
I mean, most people learn the
kinds of things you're saying,
but somebody told them that,
hey, these are practices that
really don't make sense in
a real software system.
AUDIENCE: People were, by the
time we got to the projects,
your standard pattern was highly
representative, a bunch
of flags you want to encode in
a bunch of fields, right?
And you've seen them a
couple times, it's
just a standard pattern.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so one of the
things you'll find in this
first one is that they're very
confused about the difference
between unsigned and signed, and
how shifts work, and what
happens when, you know, how come
I shifted this thing left
33 bits and I got a zero.
Why?
I thought I was shifting a
64-bit value, but in fact,
they hadn't done 1LL,
they just did 1.
And so there are things like
that, where they don't--
very low hanging fruit, if
you will, to talk about.
AUDIENCE: Did you tell them
about valgrind by the way?
Like, why would programs crash
when they said they spent a
huge amount of time debugging
these crazy C programs when
they're not used to the compiler
not protecting them.
PROFESSOR: Actually, that's a
good point because we were
going to try to introduce--
maybe we should do that as
part of the next lecture,
spend a little
bit of time on valgrind.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Because the memory
checker there is really a
pretty useful tool for them
to get correct code.
AUDIENCE: I second that.
That thing has saved my
butt so many times.
PROFESSOR: So many
times, exactly.
AUDIENCE: I've heard that, but
more low-hanging fruit for
valgrind is to always compile a
-w all to just cache all the
warning and declare all warnings
as errors, and it
just makes--
PROFESSOR: I think that
we have that as a
default in our makefile.
Is that right?
ERIC: At least for the
first project.
PROFESSOR: The first project?
AUDIENCE: I think they should
understand that in industry
practice, if you don't do
that, you're a schmuck.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yep.
Good, so that's good, and why,
in particular, the valgrind--
we discussed that last year,
and really actually, the
upcoming lecture's exactly
when we should do that.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Because
there's also another tool
called Dr. Memory.
PROFESSOR: OK, which
makes sense, yeah.
AUDIENCE: One issue that I
experienced a little last year
was that people they
specifically intend to write a
little test for their code.
They've mostly relied on a few
runs by hand, then they wrote
a progression producing things
that they ran earlier.
I guess that now you're actually
encouraging them to
actually have a test suite.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well, now they
get points off if they
didn't write enough test that
somebody else's code passed it
that had a bug.
AUDIENCE: And in this case the
testing run will be as far as
the first turn in, and then the
second turn in is just you
have a version to run
against and then
just need to optimize.
PROFESSOR: Right,
that's right.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So first,
about the actual tests they
have write a lot of tests
because that will help, and
the second, then you give
them all the tests.
So they will have a lot of test
suite to run and then of
course we have a lot of number
of points we'll deduct of you
actually fail those test.
Because they have no excuse.
PROFESSOR: There's no excuse
at that point, it's just a
question of having--
AUDIENCE: What performance and
measurement tools are you
going to be using this year?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So, right
now, we are going to give them
perf because what we found was,
the process of ECUT is so
new a lot of performance tools
don't have-- like OperaFile
didn't work, because they
haven't been ported properly.
There's no port for it yet.
So perf we are going to use, and
we are thinking of giving
them gprof in there.
And then last year gave them
couple Pintools we didn't ask
them to write anything but for
example, account number
instruction or couple of
tools they do that.
Those are main tools you get,
and also we need to go to
Cilk, you'll do a bunch of
Cilk tools in there.
AUDIENCE: Everyone last year,
they were given VTune, I think
it was, it was too hard
for them to use.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that was too
hard for them to use because
they have to use the machines
remotely, and VTune and is an
interactive tool, and so that
just made it very complicated
to do things.
So instead we're going to go
with a something that has
textual output, and is easy,
therefore, to run from command
line and has all the advantages
of running things
that you get when you run things
from command line.
AUDIENCE: So a logistical
question so, meeting on MIT is
fine, but where are there
designated places to meet?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We will
work with student to find
places for them.
For example, there are locations
for PSS students to
meet, and we are going
to get them arranged.
So if in the organizing you guys
can create probably an
online scheduling something.
What's that website?
Online is, online
scheduling is--
PROFESSOR: Doodle.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Doodle,
Doodle or something like that,
and get their times and then
they'll work with us to figure
out the place to meet, and then
they can send it out.
One thing we will have to do
is, between four students,
because every project we are
chaining the pairings, so
sometimes we might end up in a
way that, two of your students
are paired together, and then
we will tell you don't put
them together in the same group,
you'll basically have
to mix them in the other way.
If they are not in any kind
of a pairing, then you can
organize the four in
any way you want.
PROFESSOR: Actually I don't even
want of the four of them,
I don't even want us pairing.
That shouldn't be.
But we'll see what happens.
Barry?
AUDIENCE: Last year of course
was in classroom downstairs
and I just met them just
outside the classroom.
There's plenty of
little space.
PROFESSOR: Also the first floor
of STATA, I mean we've
had a lot of people just
using the first
floor of this building.
There's lots of cafe and place
there, and so forth, to sit
there, get a coffee,
and so forth.
So some people just did
something that informally,
other people wanted a more quiet
private place to talk.
And I think that we'll help the
students facilitate that.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: And the key
thing is, especially if any
students are flaking out, for
example, doesn't answer your
email, or missed the meeting,
or something like that, or
late to the meeting,
let us know.
Because that's part of their
grade, even though you're not
grading them, if they are not
participating in working with
you guys, they will get
points deducted.
So we really want to know that,
and we have tried to
emphasize that they have to act,
and actually do it right.
So we really need to know that,
if the students are not
actually cooperating
with you guys.
PROFESSOR: So I hope that this
year will have a better--
So the vast majority of people
last year had no trouble, but
we did have a couple of people
for whom it was one or two
students who just made life a
little bit miserable for their
master, and so hopefully we'll
provide a few more incentives
this year to avoid
that situation.
But they're students
and so they--
AUDIENCE: When do we find
out which students
are assigned to us?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Probably
the next two days.
OK, and then who's responsible
for contacting whom?
That's a good question.
Who should we contact?
PROFESSOR: We decided that,
didn't we, at the meeting?
What did we decide?
AUDIENCE: This is what happens
when you don't
write things down.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You have
to cover the old stuff.
PROFESSOR: Let's see, so last
time I think we had it that
the students contacted the
mentor, and then--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: What we will
do is we will set up,
we'll send the intro email to
everybody, we'll send the
intro email to the mentor, Cc
the student then saying I am
introducing you to each other.
And then one thing you can do
is immediately reply and, if
you have Peter Doodle Paul,
or something like that.
And then say, OK, look, do
you know your students?
So you can reply to that and
hopefully they will reply
back, and proceed.
So when we send you the names
you will also see the emails
of students.
PROFESSOR: Are people familiar
with doodle?
Anybody not familiar
So doodle is a website where
you can basically enter a
whole bunch of times, and then
people enter their names and
mark off which times they
can make things.
It's a poll source.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Don't do what
I did the last time, I
marked off all the times that I
cannot participate, so I was
basically the exact opposite.
PROFESSOR: It's green and red,
is what the colors they use.
So green means you can make it,
and red means you can't.
So, anyway you don't have to use
that facility, but it is a
convenient one to use.
AUDIENCE: Can we expect students
to be dropping?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: There will
be people dropping.
They just started.
This is also a group project
and at 2:00 AM we got mails
saying OK, I'm dropping the
class, and we had to scramble
trying to add a 3:00 AM
to create another
group, and so, Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You shouldn't
take dropping as a
reflection on our end.
People drop out.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You
have to know that.
PROFESSOR: You can
if you want.
AUDIENCE: I had like
three people drop
PROFESSOR: No, that
tends to be more--
AUDIENCE: I had one student,
it was awesome.
So easy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To get an idea of the
mindset the students are
going to be in this sort of a
really tough 6-170 type thing,
or is this one of the
easier classes.
PROFESSOR: No this is
a challenging class.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So
you take 6-170 that
has about four projects.
We doubled the number of
turn-ins because each project
has beta and a final, and
some projects has
two turn-ins in there.
So basically, they have all
their big projects going on,
because they are doing the
new project and they have
submitted final on the
previous project.
And they're already completed
project zero that was--
PROFESSOR: Just like
real life huh?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We gave
them project zero.
That was built to to get used to
the system and we can help
them with the class, they
have to finish this one.
So this class just screams
excess very, very--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and of course
they're students, some of them
have learned you put off things
to the end, and haven't
learned the lessons of
well not always.
So as I said, as a group they're
relatively immature
when it comes to some of these
things, but there's a large
fraction of them who are
incredibly mature about these
kinds of things.
So our job is as lecturers in
the class is to make it so
that the students
who start work
early don't get penalized.
And that's probably the hardest
thing in the software
related class because, the
classic thing is that they
want to get started, they
find all the bugs right?
And they waste their time doing
it, and if you do it
later, then the TAs have worked
all the bugs out.
So one of our challenges is to
make it so that students who
start early are rewarded by
being able to have more time
not wasting their time.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: And today was
the day that they turn in
the project and by looking at
the class, you realize they
haven't gone to sleep, and I
asked and most people haven't
slept in about 30 hours.
They have been up entire
last night and an email
conversation when I went
to sleep there was
an email train going.
Every five minutes,
something pop up.
When I woke up, the train was
still going, and amazingly,
there were a couple of TAs up
and answering all through the
night, and that kept
continuing.
So these kids they can be flaky
sometimes, but they're
amazingly hard working.
And this is only one class
they're taking.
They might be taking four
classes like that.
And I have seen people
scheduling their schedule as
by hour, scheduling and they
say, OK, look I can do the
problems set or I have
one hour of sleep.
And a lot of times that's
their thing, and then
sometimes they triage.
That's why sometimes they miss
classes, they realize, OK, I
can do the problem set, I can
sleep, I came do that.
So I think these kids
work amazingly hard.
PROFESSOR: I do think it's
helpful to also counsel them
on, hey, you can't do everything
on a death march.
You got to learn at some point
what you're capable of, and
manage your own time resources
and so forth.
Because the joke at
MIT is, classes,
friends, sleep, pick two.
The other thing, let me just
say, is that despite the
obvious sleep deprivation we
saw in the class today the
number of students who came up
after class so charged about
working on this first project
was really quite amazing.
They were all very,
very excited.
And very excited we also gave
them the initial feedback on
the performance, and you could
see, there's one group of
students who clearly got it, and
then there's another tier
of students who didn't get it
quite this much, and then
there's the ones who their code
has errors and stuff.
There's no doubt that there are
a lot of students who are
very charged about this.
This is a fun class but
it's a hard class.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: I think
you'll find this is true.
They will be, probably tired,
but they will be soaking up
this information like a
sieve, and sometimes
I found last year's--
After the looking at the first
set of code, some of those the
masters were really upset.
How can you teach you guys,
these guys write this kind of
bad code, but when they realized
after they said
something, this is getting
into their heads.
I mean, they're improving
they're actually changing.
These guys are very smart,
and they're looking
for you guys for--
They're basically sponge,
really empty sponge.
They're going absorb a
lot in this class.
PROFESSOR: I have a 2 and 1/2
year old at home, and it's
amazing what the progress is
she's made in six months.
She talking now in complete
sentences, and so forth, it's
just really amazing how how
she does it, and these
students are like that.
They start out and you say, oh
my God, they have no skills
whatsoever.
By the end of the term the
progress that they've made is
really astounding.
You just say, gee if you could
just keep on that trajectory
your whole life.
But really, they really are very
smart, and they come up
to speed very, very fast,
especially given good
counseling.
The main thing that they need
right now is just the
attention so somebody actually
can look at their code and
say, you know you did it like
this it would be better code.
Any other questions or issues?
This is lots of fun.
If you run into any troubles,
we're right here,
just send us email.
And as I say they're young and
immature, but then you get to
see them grow, of course some of
them will flake out on you,
but the vast majority, you'll
see, are really very dedicated
and well meaning.
They really want to do a good
job in the class, and really,
really find the class
very exciting.
Our numbers, in fact, almost
doubled for last year.
So the reputation got around
that this was a
good class to be doing.
And the other thing is, right
now what I really like about
the class, the students right
now compared with
say 10 years ago.
So 10 years ago we had the
Internet boom, and there were
all kinds of students taking
computer science because they
thought it was a ticket to
fortune and so forth.
And now we're back to what it
was pre-2000, 1998, whatever.
Where the vast majority of
students who are taking the
class really enjoy
engineering.
They really enjoy
the software.
the engineering.
The fact that you end up with
a pretty good job and
opportunity sometimes to do
entrepreneurship, and
opportunity to explore things,
it's sort of like, oh that's a
fringe benefit.
But what they're really after
is just the intellectual
excitement and so forth.
So it's really quite fun to
work with the students and
quite rewarding.
Really very nice type of class
to have right now, where the
students taking it because
they're actually interested in
the material, not because it
buys them a bread ticket, meal
ticket, whatever.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: The standard, is the
coding standard in the
reference, the standard is to
consider for them provided?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: I don't
think we have set up a
standard, per se.
What we want them
to do is kind of
create their own style.
It's like in a writing class,
you don't give them a standard
writing guideline is to follow
this one, you don't constrain
them to that.
We want to give them the
opportunity to grow into their
style, but kind of guide them,
so that they don't make the
classic mistakes.
That's why we need you guys, I
mean, if there's a standard,
we can come up with a standard,
create a script to
actually check the standard, and
then say, OK, thou shall
follow the standard.
And you can do that and
everybody will hate it.
You can't make that
bad happen.
One thing you want to do is
make them lifelong good
coders, not something they
realize OK, I need to do this
to get this grade, and I'm going
to abandon everything
and convince myself never
to that again.
And we have had sometimes, like
when we needed all this
software engineering.
We went through things like
thou shall write all the
preconditions and
postconditions, and everything
will be graded.
And people did it, but half of
them got into them and said
this is good things.
Other half, they didn't realize
why they're doing it,
they just hated it.
And I don't think they
left assuming I would
never do this again.
So the key thing here is,
we don't want force
something on to them.
We want them to come through a
natural process, and I think a
lot of them, can, when they
understand what they're doing,
they'll develop a really
good kind of practice.
PROFESSOR: It's also the case, I
think, that coding standards
vary culturally from place to
place, and the what people
expect in one place is different
from what thing.
So being too prescriptive means,
as Saman is saying,
that it becomes a grammatical
thing, rather than is this
code organized.
The real thing, coding standards
are very important,
especially in large software
organizations of course, so
that everybody can tell what's
going on in any particular
piece of code without having
been the author.
But in this kind of thing where
we have something that's
relatively small, what we're
mostly interested in is the
organizational aspects of coding
style, as opposed to
the grammatical ones.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So also don't
impose your standard and
say, my company this is what we
do, I want to follow that.
Just figure out and kind of
guide them towards something
while they're maturing, and
try to make it better.
That's the thing.
That's why you cannot have
a cookie-cutter model.
PROFESSOR: And why it's good
to have senior software
engineers who understand what's
really important, as
opposed to what might be
required in any particular
individual situation.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: One other
topic I want to add is
sometimes when you have two
students, there might be a
case that one person might be
very talkative and dominating,
and one person might be just a
listener, and so you have to
keep an eye on that and make
sure that you give the other
person opportunities to talk,
and because it might
be just like that.
Encouragement and stuff like
that, so make sure that you
get both of them to talk.
And also the are supposed to be
responsible for all the code.
You should not let them get away
by saying, oh my partner
wrote it, so I don't
understand.
So that's not a good answer.
So get them to actually go
through that, and if they
don't come prepared tell them
that, and you can give them
some feedback, as a next
time can you please
do, this and this.
Because they also don't know
what to expect, and we give
them a little bit of guideline,
but it'll be good,
also for you, the first time
around, if you find some
mistakes also for the next code
review you can encourage
them what to do, how to prepare
and what to do.
Don't give them too much work,
because we're already giving
them enough work.
Don't ask them to write extra
documentation, but you can say
it would have been nice if you
had this level of preparation,
if you could have explained to
me, or given me a summary, or
something like that.
So something like that is
something you can expect.
And the other thing is if you
had to figure out how we want
to do code review.
So, for example, you might want
to bring your laptop, or
ask them to bring a laptop in
there, if you want each other
to look at the code on the
computer, so ask them to bring
the laptops or something.
So think about the logistics
of how you're going to do
that, and that'll be useful.
PROFESSOR: And I think any other
sort of expectations you
have, in your email to them
the first time say, here's
what I'd like you.
I think it's helpful to say I'd
like you to come prepared
to give me a five minute update
on how you did each of
the problems, for example.
We will be telling them that,
but to have it come directly
from you means--
The difference if I say go do
this to that person, versus
you're coming to me
and expecting it.
Good.
So, I want to once again, I
can't thank you folks enough
for being willing to
give your time.
Time is the stuff life is made
out of, so I really appreciate
your willingness to volunteer
your time for these students,
and I really think you have a
dramatically meaningful impact
on the students.
The students may or may not
fully appreciate that, OK, but
Saman and I really appreciate
that, and we will make sure
the students appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just have one.
What what are the guidelines for
a contact outside of the
code reviews with
the students.
I mean are they, can we have
them email us with questions
about the process and just
kind of general guidance
PROFESSOR: It's your level of
tolerance we don't want you to
have to commit more than about
20 hours across the term,
because then it becomes
onerous.
But if you're willing I think
it's completely open ended, in
terms of how much else.
I mean it's one thing if you go
into solving their problems
for them, that we don't want you
doing, but when it comes
to, especially the quality, and
non-metrical aspects of
programming, the more you can
give them the better, OK?
Because it's only making them
be better programmers.
And I think the fact that there
may be some unevenness
in that across the masters
is irrelevant.
Really, I do not want to hold
back some students from
getting good mentorship because
somebody else is not
getting the same level of
attention, et cetera.
But really, no expectation
there, on our part, to do more
than the code reviews
themselves.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So, that said
I want to make sure that
you aren't answering their
question, at some point I
don't want to be a
crutch for them.
For example, if they say, OK,
before prebeta, they say OK,
this is my next problem, can you
on a little bit, I didn't
understand.
If you have that, so they're
trying to get too much into
that level, kind of making you
their programmer, or something
like that, just let us know.
A lot of these things, there
will be a lot of cases that
arise that we haven't
thought through.
The students are ingenious
enough they will find a lot of
loopholes, a lot of kind of
interesting things that we
never thought through.
So if you find something that
you're not feeling comfortable
just send a mail and say
OK, take a look.
PROFESSOR: It really is, if
their questions are about
course content it's not
appropriate for you folks to
be dealing with, really.
OK, that's what our TAs are
for, and course staff.
If it's about coding style and
engineering practice, and even
time management, or anything
that's sort of the
non-technical aspects, but
things that have a strong
impact on technical, that yes.
Anything you can provide
there is great.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So if you
find anything that's outside
the norm of what we discussed
if you feel a little bit
uncomfortable, just
send email.
Send an email, and say,
hey, can I do this?
Is it OK, for me to do this?
And then we can always provide
guidance, so we are
responsible.
PROFESSOR: --do something and
say after the fact, oh, it
went past, let us know.
There's rarely anything you can
do on one shot basis that
is heinous or unrecoverable
from, or whatever, so.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: It
is always good,
I mean that's why--
since we see everybody able to
and we have done these kind of
situation before.
We can just easily
tell you what.
PROFESSOR: But, mentor them,
for sure, mentor them.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: I think a lot
of times, when you talk to
students last time they got a
lot more information out from
the masters, other than
just the coding style.
I mean, they talk about what is
it like to be an engineer
in a company, what
are the things?
And so they get a good feel.
I mean, some of them might
not have done a
internship in a company.
So they don't know.
I mean, they're just green, and
talking to you guys they
get a feel for what it's like.
And also from a non-marketing
situation too.
I mean you might have ulterior
motives to market your company
to them, and stuff, but this is
not that they're going into
a job interview.
So, for a lot of
them it's rare.
I mean they might not have
retinues of friends that they
can go and talk at that
kind of casual level.
Most of the time they're on
guard because they're on an
interview or they assume that
information coming to them
will be sugar-coated, and here
is a way that they can get--
I think it's very
good for them.
PROFESSOR: Eight minutes
over time.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
I think we should.
PROFESSOR: So, any last
final comments?
Saman and I will hang around for
a few minutes, for anybody
wants to chat more one one.
And one and once again I thank
you for all the time that
you're planning to put into
the 6-172, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.